the choice had closed with joy it's
like a toast with psychedelic butter
but it's beautiful wow they almost seem to have
a human being
wow it's not good it's not bad right
I think you have to change this toast for
something else
approx 6 flex today as you say  it's
going to explode
I think it's important to be careful
it makes a little noise when you eat
it sounds like it's inside your head
if you can't hear your own
thoughts without knowing already the ngo in your mouth
eating this the index
she maria him right in the navy no  subject
is extremely harmful I just wouldn't eat
optic 5 at once the picker
me is never very special
there's no problem with having done
it they don't know right
it wasn't made by mother nature
clarifies plastic and the most
artificial thing I've ever eaten in mine  life is
plastic as once modeled
that is also good to attack in colleagues
neither strawberry and vanilla nor from dossiers
net nothing to a strawberry background for
his arrangement so I will leave  a on the table to
see an
aroma alt